[Music]
in not what I paid for news submitted by
free 99 a man destroyed his own
brand-new condo for not being luxurious
enough wait he destroyed it he destroyed
his own privilege no what does he I just
have so many condos I just have to say
that this is my dream come true
oh it's a video he recorded himself
doing it yes oh we had someone recorded
did you see the video about the guy that
destroyed his house after the Cowboys
lost because that one's pretty this guy
[ __ ] destroys his counter and like
smashes his TV because the couch it's so
funny though that I guess this was a
championship game playoff game or super
yeah anyway yeah he wants kids TV so
this is the Malaysia or this takes place
in Malaysia this millionaire dude he
paid 2 million ringgit which is about
four hundred eighty six thousand dollars
for a luxury condo that's a lot for out
there where is it Malaysia
yeah and so Hugh st. so he made this
video pointing out all the cheap stuff
in his condo he was like impeccable tape
just you gotta watch it okay okay I'm
ready he designed this condo so no so
it's like property like the building
what do they call it like it comes
furnished or something one of those
complex yeah exactly so the property
developer so they're the ones that but
he doesn't get to pick it isn't he the
one that's like yes I'm gonna choose
this well yeah so he picked the one that
cost like the most luxurious one out of
whatever it is that they have up like a
boss it's not gold peas on it no so
you'll see yeah let's watch it don't
taste I'll ever get that hand
I make it for you otherwise media very
almost every piece there's any warning
his own [ __ ] so much money a beeper I
wants to get his money back
yeah he's marking the stuff that he
wants them with she doesn't have shoes
on that is fun that is fun gonna live
here this is gonna be the show room for
the next people that want to buy the
property so he's like I'm gonna show
people because you're a liar like you
you just pretty much stole my money
and I'm his son jr. if I pay 400 grand
and and I got some cheap-ass materials
like that I would have been like wow
well I'm just confused cuz before you
buy something don't you like go in there
and check it out maybe over there you
don't brand new building yeah because my
review I do want to see the layout well
maybe they don't have an escrow the way
we do it like for us we have
walkthroughs there's like 30 days maybe
over there is you just buy it buy can
see it's like yeah it's the building is
still being built no you
upfront and then when the date comes
here's your keys did you see a picture
my mom was looking at she wanted to buy
a condo in Japan and it was like the
building wasn't even built yet so then
they gave her like PDF renderings of
everything and then she's like I like it
I want to design it like this so
technically I guess if you want to be
early you'll you'll be one of those
people but then yeah later on they'll
probably have a showroom but I bet you
anything even if they did had a showroom
that was like a bait-and-switch moves
better yeah that's what he's so pissed
and everyone online is on his side too
because they're like yeah I mean that
sucks like he also should because this
video was really long so the beginning
of it he shows how they had these
sliding doors but you have to stick your
finger in this hole to like get the door
out and there are other people there
with him and like they were even kind of
struggling getting it out and he's like
how is this he's like how is this your
impeccable taste I'm kind of depressed
though cuz like I paid way more than
that from my house and we are the
outlets in my office haven't worked for
two years I'm a ceiling fan fell out in
the spare bedroom we just let we're like
what do we do welcome to LA yeah there
is no I wish I could've did you have a
house that was built in 1920 or
something like that
yeah and then flips like contractor just
trying to flip it quick and running
cheap [ __ ] and it looks really pretty
but that's what you do to like be able
to afford a house that you don't deal
with it a poverty level house here is
still half a million oh yeah so it was
no much depressed shopping for houses
and I was so depressing it really is
this is my price range
well this is a piece of [ __ ] they're not
even they didn't clean up for me to come
in dude we shot for two years and there
was so there were two taxes and in
between so I had to pay taxes twice and
each time it just took a chunk of that
downpayment so each time we went down a
bracket in the houses that we were
looking at was so mind-numbing I hate it
and then as the markets going up so it's
like yeah we were about to go to Vegas
yeah [ __ ] LA yeah we [ __ ] love it
here so much but we get less
boxes and it's only a 45-minute flight
plus they don't have like asthma
income-tax there and they don't have
layoffs if you want to run a business
it's not like this [ __ ] $800 fee to
just run a business yes they have like a
very low capital gains tax there it's
dry and it's depressing but you could
get a pool for probably air if you drive
yeah and it's really when it's hot it
you get a humidifier true I like nature
yeah you like la I'm in Pasadena I live
in your mountains Pasadena is really
nice ten minutes away you could build
your own mountain out there and still
have money left over you are right about
that I could plant my own trees you know
whoa and you build like the little
nature of anymore we just bought a house
you can't move anymore that's what we
said after we bought our house and you
still wanted to move it we did it moves
out because we're like oh all right baby
like you just bought a house no it's one
of my dreams is to one of your dreams
one of my dreams it's when I'm super
rich is I want to forest a desert but I
don't think I convert the climate you
can do it you just don't water your [ __ ]
no you can do it in like a dome like
Singapore like where they have no China
and Africa and desert areas there they
have so much yeah I like the grass so
much fun you're gonna change the
ecosystem but it's because your wolves
are gonna coyotes are gonna die because
of you know it's to help the ecosystem
you don't know it's supposed to be a
desert me we made it into a desert we
did yeah we did it oh we did it
mhm my bad I just wanna I want one
mountain like in the middle of the
Mojave Desert it's like full of trees
and birds and [ __ ] yeah and then like
people that are thirsty can come mmm I
couldn't waste this yep or water but we
have water bottles but if they look
weird I shoot them no cuz what if but if
they look where'd you shoot them what if
okay imagine you're on a road trip to
Vegas with with Bart right I didn't the
car breaks down because Bart wanted to
go off-road a little bit it happens
right and you're like oh [ __ ] what are
we gonna do no reception reception yeah
in this story there is no
I want them to come to me I want to feel
like Jesus I want them to come to me and
I'm like you need my help
well guess what come on in that's a bar
stools for he has a sandbar in the in
the lake so it looks like you are we're
all just destroying history I'm trying
to combat our [ __ ] ozone layer
problem and our [ __ ] gas problems but
you guys want to keep it [ __ ] up I'm
trying to force up the native the desert
won't you for us up some forest yeah the
Amazon could be they already got tree
it's easier you just put water I don't
want to do that [ __ ] easier I want a
challenge yep we'll do this tomorrow
we're gonna strip you naked we're gonna
drop in the desert and then you just go
plant some trees I will see you in a
year
well you got to give me a half all the
seeds just give you a bag of fruits in
their seed
oh I like that edible forest yeah that's
pretty cool
you set up an irrigation system that's a
lot of work yeah you gotta be really
rich you know why I got this idea so the
former CEO of Church's Chicken I think
it was Church's Chicken he moved to West
Texas and out there it's like a very
desert like Rockland right and then he
got the most shadiest piece of land
there with nothing and then he figured
out a way to make it live oh yeah you
should make an island out of it put him
boat around already know what he's gonna
do he's gonna build another [ __ ]
Vegas yeah it's gonna turn he's gonna
start with seed then he's gonna be like
I'm [ __ ] bored I miss playing
blackjack it's gonna be another casino
and then the Mafia is gonna come after
you yeah dad I'm coming yeah
all right so back to this guy in
Malaysia the impeccable taste yeah so in
the video he says I don't have time to
go to tribunal which is Court there will
be a group of people who will have time
to go for the tribunal let them go wait
until you deal with those mainland
Chinese buyers and then you'll see what
they do they will do even more and so
what he's saying is wait till like the
mainland Chinese people are buying the
same condo that you've swindled me into
and they're gonna [ __ ] you over even
more oh he's talking to the really ugly
more ruthless than him that's what he's
saying
so this place is called topic Tropicana
corporation per head and so they even
posted on their Facebook page dear
valued customers business partners and
stakeholders we are aware of videos
being circulated in regards to one of
our service residences at in Kuala
Lumpur pretty much are saying that the
person in this video that guy he is an
employee of the rightful owner and that
he's not even the one that nobody yeah
exactly that's what worried about me
that's exactly what everyone's saying
like so our argument bill has permission
from the owner obviously to just right
by Gary both of you - say that like he
didn't have permission just right like
who is that it doesn't even change the
fact that they have shitty call no logic
yes they're like he's not the owner
though what does he know about quality
because if I was like a mega millionaire
- I would hire someone to do it so then
no one knows who I am
Yeah right I'd want to be secret yes I
curious - this guy so they're just
saying like you know the toy loyal
customers were we sincerely thank you
and all this will show you they're like
we still are committed towards
continuously delivering quality homes
with an impeccable team yeah with
impeccable taste but when he was like
mmm
impeccable taste huh probably telling
all his friends you know I got an
apartment it's impeccable tasty and he's
all excited he opens the doors I walked
off [ __ ] this is not impeccable this
tasters not impeccable
[Music]
[Music]